tu sais l'armoire à pharmacie c'est que
la loi avec une consommation de 48
boîtes de médicaments par an les
français font partie des plus gros
consommateurs d'europe en la matière
tranches de vie sur ordonnance c'est le
nom de cette pièce qui remet en question
notre relation entretenue avec notre
pharmacie une comédie qui casse
certaines idées reçues et du progrès à
faire par rapport à nos comportements
plus d'être responsable il faudrait
éviter ce réflexe de surconsommer et
d'aller comme on a la chance d'avoir un
système de sécurité sociale qui
fonctionne encore pas mal les gens
achètent des médicaments parce qu'ils
surconsommation automédication
médicaments génériques
autant de thèmes abordés lors de cette
pièce assez particulière puisque le
public directement mises à contribution
ce qui est bon droit et est même invité
à monter sur scène
en fin de compte ce n'est que le reflet
de votre vie un peu boboland médicaments
stocker surconsommation auto médicaments
c'est cesser le quotidien fait non
parler c'est bien et puis d'avoir fait
rigoler les gens si cela peut faire
transporter le message c'est barbant un
régime mais il faut savoir le faire mais
échoue peu pompeux diminuer les doses
plutôt que de tout supprimer c'est une
bonne solution
je pense que tu peux ludique je pense
aussi qu'ils retiennent mieux dans le
fait où ils ont participé eux mêmes
c'est pas quelque chose de didactique
c'est pas quelqu'un qui leur a dit on
fait comme si on fait comme ça c'est moi
je suis d'aller sur scène et j'ai fait à
l'est tels jeux destinés aux seniors
tranches de vie sur ordonnance ont pièce
interactive qui apporte des conseils en
poussant le public à s'interroger lui
même sur sa propre consommation
une manière de placer le spectateur en
acteur et sujet principal de la pièce
avec un seul objectif favoriser un bon
usage des médicaments